revista de prensa de hoy viernes 26 de
noviembre ya está lista en el estudio
rosa pérez + dedo para traernos lo mejor
de la prensa internacional vamos a
comenzar entonces rosa con una
investigación que he tenido mucho
impacto en francia ha sido realizada por
el medio independiente this close y se
llama edit papers los memorandos del
terror porque rosa exacto y raúl es una
investigación que ha tenido muchísimo
impacto y de la cual se han hecho eco
distintas cabeceras francesas esta
investigación se basa en la filtración
de cientos de documentos confidenciales
del ministerio de defensa francés
documentos archivos que abordan la
relación de cooperación en términos
militares y de inteligencia entre
francia y egipto en el marco de una
supuesta lucha antiterrorista sin
embargo lo que señala esta investigación
es que esta cooperación que empezó bajo
el mandato de françois hollande y que
continuó y sigue todavía vigente a día
de hoy bajo la presidencia de
pues que egipto el régimen de alfie si
utiliza los recursos los recursos
suministrados por francia para a la
práctica perseguir a lo que llama
contrabandistas inmigrantes irregulares
que cruzan la frontera entre libia y
egipto o para por ejemplo espiar también
a activistas pues que son anti a
gubernamentales que van en contra del
régimen de alciser básicamente estas
informaciones y este pues material
militar como por ejemplo aviones que
sobrevuelan el desierto ha sido
utilizado para incluso bombardear como
comentábamos camionetas donde se
encontraban decenas de civiles el número
de muertos causados por informaciones
suministradas pues por francia es
todavía desconocido pero lo que apunta
esta investigación y a lo que es grave
de la cuestión es como en reiteradas
ocasiones tanto el gobierno de alan como
el de macrón ha sido alertado por el
personal francés que se encontrase que
se encuentra sobre el terreno de esta
este mal uso de los recursos
por parte del régimen ande al sisi y que
francia ha hecho oídos sordos a estas
alertas y de hecho aprovecha este marco
de cooperación para vender armas a
egipto excelente e investigación rosa
pero ahora vamos a cerrar esta semana
con un tema que empezamos ayer y que
tuvo mucho recibimiento de parte de
nuestros televidentes nuestra audiencia
seguimos entonces con los momentos más
destacados de 2021 a través de las 100
fotografías seleccionadas por la revista
'time' exacto raúl ayer nos dio tiempo
de comentar por ejemplo las protestas en
mianmar también aquí en colombia el fin
de la era merkel entre otras cosas pero
nos quedaron fuera varios temas que han
marcado este año como por ejemplo el
asalto del capitolio no hay varias
fotografías que hemos seleccionado de
este momento no sé si nuestros
compañeros allí pues las vemos no
distintas instantáneas de este momento
que dejó con los ojos abiertos de todo
el mundo y que se está investigando
precisamente ahora y con muchas
preguntas que señalan al ex presidente
de trump recordemos que también su ex
consejero steve banon pues está acusado
por desacato por la justicia federal por
no haberse presentado ante la comisión
de investigación del congreso aquí
veíamos también kamala harris en la
investidura
joe biden traspasar el plan de
infraestructuras aquí viven con su
homólogo putin en ginebra también la
violencia racial ha marcado este año ahí
veíamos a ver si nos pueden pasar un
momentito este este gráfico veíamos la
retirada en ritmo también en eeuu de
esta estatua confederada no aquí vemos
la familia de georges fueron celebrando
la condena por asesinato de derecho o
bing porque bueno recordemos derecho
bien el ex policía que asesinó pues a
georg floyd en mineápolis ahí veíamos
espero pido también que nos vuelvan a
pausar porque veíamos la otra cara de la
moneda precisamente en algo que sucedió
hace pocos días y es que fue absuelto
pues este hombre
kyle rittenhouse
a pesar de haber matado a dos
protestantes durante unas protestas
también en contra de la violencia racial
no la otra cara de la moneda en la
justicia en eeuu aquí es una foto de los
en haití y raúl bueno este país que
vivió este terremoto en agosto un mes
después del asesinato del magnicidio del
ex presidente joven en la murcia podemos
continuar con las imágenes a ver si
los además recordamos que bueno ahí está
también esto de periodistas afganos
torturados por a los las autoridades tal
y vamos a descubrir una manifestación de
mujeres en afganistán las imágenes son
pues bueno dieron también la vuelta del
supuesto entra cosas comunes fosas
comunes en libia raúl en esta década de
guerra ya en el país donde intervienen
distintas fuerzas extranjeras distintas
milicias seguimos con el accidente del
metro en méxico donde murieron 26
personas
no sé cómo vamos de tiempo si no nos
queda mucho te pediría pasar
directamente esto sur site en florida
donde murieron casi 100 personas por
este derrumbe el arresto de esta
militante después del feminicidio de
sara de vergara en reino unido si la
violencia de las fronteras estos en
belarús le hacían lo mismo aquí en
colombia en el darién y pediría pasar a
la última parte que hemos seleccionado
porque ha sido un año también de
esperanza por las vacunas no contra el
cubit 19 pediría a nuestros compañeros
que sí a ver si pueden avanzar las
gráficas es que creo que no sé no se va
a poder por el sistema cómo avanzar
hasta la última rosa pero pues igual
invitamos a nuestros televidentes que
nos sigan en revista de prensa y que
puede ver por supuesto la fotografías en
la revista 'time' bueno raúl pues aquí
ya lo dejamos así entonces lo invitamos
como comentas a nuestra audiencia a
entrar y ver estas maravillosas 100
fotografías que resumen muy bien lo que
hemos vivido a lo largo de este año rosa
muchísimas gracias entonces por toda la
información esta revista de prensa nos
vemos el lunes con más ahora vamos a
pasar a nuestro primer invitado del día